c'est l'une des rares vidéos
apparaissent deux américain porté
disparu en ukraine elles ont été filmées
par des soldats russes les deux hommes
d'anciens militaires apparaissent
menotté après avoir donné des nouvelles
sur leur état de santé il dit s'être
rendu aux troupes russes suite à des
combats près de rares kiffe le lieu de
leur détention n'est pas indiqué après
plusieurs jours de silence moscou a
officiellement réagi à cette capture ce
sont des mercenaires et il était
impliqué dans des activités illégales
sur le territoire de l'ukraine notamment
dans des tirs et des bombardements sur
des militaires russes ils doivent être
tenus responsables des crimes qu'ils ont
commis leur sort suscite la plus grande
inquiétude ne pas les reconnaître comme
des militaires revient pour moscow à ne
pas respecter la convention de genève
sur le sort des prisonniers de guerre le
kremlin a aussi indiqué que le recours à
la peine de mort n'était pas exclue
l'afer est suivi de près à washington
interpellé sur le sujet avant la
publication des vidéos joe biden a
réitéré son appel à la plus grande
prudence
je répète que les américains ne
devraient pas se rendre en ukraine
maintenant les américains ne devraient
pas se rendre en ukraine un troisième
américain est toujours porté disparu
depuis le début du conflit au moins deux
combattants volontaires originaires des
etats unis ont perdu la vie en ukraine